I thought the wells was that's
impossible
this is the reverse-flash killed my
mother
the same person
are you sure that's why it's Barry
you
hey youtubers happy Easter so there's a
new trailer for episode 18 of the flash
that's gonna be all start team up that's
the atom crossover so I'm gonna do a
breakdown to that and explain some of
the big announcements that people around
the show have made WonderCon just
happened they didn't say a whole lot
about arrow and the flash but we did
learn a little bit about the villains of
arrow season 4 I know I haven't posted a
Q&A for this we get for the air on flash
but because they are on break and
because my schedule is gonna be a little
bit different I'll try and work
something in later this week I'll
explain the schedule changes at the end
of the video but let's talk a little bit
about Emily Kinney who's playing
bug-eyed bandit as we see in the trailer
it looks like someone's hacking into
STAR Labs
that's probably Emily Kenny's character
we don't really know why we do know that
her character works at mercury labs a
competitor in the comics her character's
name is Bertram larvan so it's it's just
like a gender bent version of that
character because they wanted to be a
felicity villain as much as she's an
atom villain it's just in the comics
bug-eyed bandit debuted in the atom his
first issue was atom number 26 that was
that was way back in 1966 and of course
Carmine Infantino was somewhere on the
title he wasn't the writer he didn't
create the character but he was
executive editor at the time I just like
how many season 1 flash villains have
been from Carmine Infantino 'he's time
he created most of the Rogues that's why
i say that the characters actually
appeared in a bunch of crossover it's
like he was in a brave in the bold comic
but typically whenever he appears in
other comics he's following the atom
around so it's like atom crossovers like
The Brave and the bold title was an atom
aquaman crossover so he's more of an
atom villain so if we see Emily Kinney
after this episode it'll probably be
when the atom crosses over with another
show like if he crosses over with the
flash again or if he crosses over with
arrow I'm expecting that crossovers will
get a little bit crazier next year just
because of the spin-off series but I'll
try to explain that a little bit Stephen
Amell just teased that the way they do
the show's is gonna change in the next
season so I'll try to explain what I
think that means mostly I think it's the
way they plot story arcs I think is just
gonna make it easier for them to do
crossover stories like stories that are
much bigger the crossover series is
gonna be like a midseason show they
haven't confirmed a whole lot of details
about that yet but it sounds like what's
gonna happen is is they're gonna like
create some big problem on arrow in the
flash and it's gonna take the team up
show to help clean it up they'll be
talking more about that at Comic Con
this
summer so I'll be sure to post updates
as they confirm stuff but they're still
assembling the cast so like there's
still a lot of stuff that they haven't
figured out yet the really fun thing
that everyone needs to keep their eyes
peeled for in this next episode of the
flash though is hive Easter eggs I know
a lot of you were asking what is the
connection between bug-eyed bandit and
hive in the comics hive is a slightly
different organization than what they
portray it as on arrow
right now all we know about hive is is
that they were responsible for ordering
the hit on Biggles brother David Ramsey
confirmed that they're gonna pursue that
plot point into season 4 like hive will
be a much bigger thing in season 4 which
I think unofficially confirms that the
Big Bad will be tied to hive in season 4
it's not huge news I think we all
expected at some point that we're gonna
pursue a high plot point there like one
of the very few big villain
organizations that arrows developed but
hasn't explored yet it's like on the
short list of big evil organizations the
DC Comics has that arrow is capable of
doing have it just really near the top
of the list although to be fair they're
really featured more in Teen Titans
stories which i think is kind of funny
because TBS has that Titans live-action
show they're doing
maybe it's like first-come first-serve
kind of thing there hasn't been any
confirmation about her character having
ties to hive or anything like that it
was just she has such a bee motif it
feels like it fits too perfectly if the
producers are gonna try and make story
arcs next season for flash and arrow
more crossover friendly it just makes
sense that they would try to create more
shared villains so if they turn hive
into a more tech based organization and
they create some more tech based
villains it just makes it easier for
villains to bounce back and forth
between both shows I think the real
question is is is would they ever
entertain a situation whereby the big
bad on arrow also ends up being the big
bad on the flash as much as they want
these shows to cross over I do think
that like the main villain on each show
will still be specific to each group of
characters what I think will end up
happening is is they'll just be like
unique sets of problems the team flash
will need team arrows help with like
Felicity for instance and vice-versa the
really funny thing about like all these
crossovers is they said that they were
really only gonna do like one flash
versus arrow type crossover like where
you do you know a two-hour story arc
across both shows once a season I guess
what they meant is is like a shared
self-contained story because episode 19
of the flash is called who is hair
and wells it's gonna be Cisco and Joe
going to Starling city to get help from
Laurel and Quentin in their
investigation and the same goes for
all-star team up with Ray Palmer going
to get new tech for his atom suit so
there are a lot of crossover stories but
it's all like built on the backbone of
like the main arc like Harrison wells
reverse-flash
Ray Palmer turning into the atom really
what we need next is confirmation as to
like how the spin-off series fits with
the main storylines on air on the flash
like is there gonna be a problem in the
finale of both shows that's gonna
require the team-up just to jump over to
the Marvel TV universe or the Netflix
universe everybody probably knows about
daredevil that's coming and there's
gonna be Jessica Jones Luke Cage iron
fist and then they'll team up in the
defenders Phil Coulson is supposed to be
the one that's gonna assemble that team
like he's gonna build that team out the
same way that Nick Fury built the
Avengers jumping back to the arrow
universe now like who's gonna be the one
to assemble that DC team is it gonna be
Ray Palmer there's gonna be Oliver or
it's gonna be like Martin Stein I know
everyone's still wondering about the
Gorilla Grodd scenes from the the
previous trailer - it looks like he's
gonna be back in episode 21 there's also
a confirmed rogue team-up but really
like the last couple of episodes of the
flash are gonna be dedicated to the
reverse-flash storyline like what is a
Oh Bart Dawn's ultimate plan and is it
moving towards flashpoint or like some
other big comic book moment everyone's
thinking it's going to flashpoint but
they're really like a number of big
things that they could do from the
comics we could see like more of a flash
rebirth type ending or it could be
something from way back in the Golden
Age I think the reason everyone thinks
flashpoint is just because like it's
such a common denominator it was a big
Justice League animated movie so there's
like really big awareness for it that's
actually really good jumping-off point
so here let me know in the comments
really big question do you guys like the
TV shows doing things that you've seen
in the comics or are you happier when
they do things that you've never seen
before there's whether this fine line
with the comic book stuff where it's
like you know yeah I want to see this
big storyline that I read like ten years
ago but I also want to see them do
something really badass that I've never
seen before
so it's like they have to balance those
two things just to explain the schedule
changes so Aaron flash are on break this
week I'll still do a bonus video but
they'll be back the 14th and the 15th be
sure to subscribe to get those videos if
there's anything specifically you guys
really want me to do just let me know in
the comments
because the DC stuff is kind of on a
break this week I'm gonna take the
opportunity to do a little bit more
Marvel stuff and Game of Thrones because
Game of Thrones and daredevil are both
premiering next weekend
Gotham is also coming back on Monday
night too so there'll be actually a new
Gotham episode and they just announced a
couple more classic Batman villains that
are coming to season two so I'll talk
about them in that Gotham video so you
should all have plenty of reasons to get
hyped we have Game of Thrones daredevil
Gotham is back all kinds of awesome
stuff so if you guys haven't seen it you
can click here for my non-spoilery
daredevil episode 1 & 2 review and you
can click here for all my flash and
arrow videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five Happy
Easter
you